a police chase is what we first heard of
that there had been reports of more
bloodshed now suggesting that perhaps
that is not the case hopefully that is
not the case but we are being told a
thousand to fifteen hundred police and
Jean de Marie are being mobilized to the
area this is only going to end one way
isn't it well I think that that is the
issue that the French security forces
are going to face they first of all have
to try and calm this down it as you say
it's fast moving but the fast moving
situation is extremely dangerous for any
hostage involved firstly secondly they
will want to try to take these men alive
because they need to get the
intelligence from them to try to find
out what their motives were and whether
or not they're part of a wider
conspiracy and what those implications
are for the longer term in terms of
France but in the immediate term the
whole thing will be the effort is about
containment try to get these individuals
into an environment in which they're no
longer on the move and then to try and
open as we're hearing there are reports
from the French that there are
negotiations underway though there may
be negotiations underway with them that
is a good sign that is a good thing as
far as the security forces of concern
they want to be able to contain it
control it comet